[Music]
[Applause]
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host nbc sports nfl analyst let's uh
start where we left off with cooper cup
value wise not talking about you know
devante adams talent or deandre hamp you
know any of that just value to his team
where does cooper cup rank this year in
your opinion
well it's up there first off like the
the talent thing's real like people got
to stop shortchanging the guy you know
what about the talents not real how many
how many 50-yard catches do we have to
see him run by everybody where we go you
know what he is fast i mean i know he's
white and he ran a 4-6 of the combine
but he's fast like i mean you know but
he legitimately is and you made a great
point there with some of the names you
talked about you know again not
everybody is great or was taught the
right way to run the 40. that's more
times or not what happens to those guys
now value to the team dan you know as
far as non-quarterbacks are concerned
yeah it's up there with
you know i think a devante adams debo
samuel jonathan taylor well i think you
put it in that list right there i'd go
those are probably the three most non
you know important quarterbacks in
football really and of course come from
that you know shanahan coaching tree
where they know how to feature a guy but
he can do everything you know i don't
know have you ever met cooper cup or
seen him in person dan no
he's bigger than you think you know he
really is he's six one six two ish you
know and of course yes the the quickness
is real the the smarts and evaluating
coverage and all that are really good
but the talent's real too it is and and
they know how to uh you know get it all
out of them that's for sure but i want
quickness over speed
yeah i hear you at every position like i
i want my running back to be quick to
get to the hole i want my linemen to be
able to be quick to to get out in space
or my wide receivers i love quickness
speed can take a while and what do you
do with that speed quickness i can
you're talking about yeah you're talking
about like acceleration right like you
know you want you want more acceleration
too out of that quickness importance
certainly acceleration's probably the
most important thing you can talk about
at times yes there's no doubt about that
hey you can get also though like a guy
like where i know i've mis-evaluated
coming out in the draft and i always
kind of call this like the peter work
syndrome a little bit like the clyde
edwards hilaire right he's very quick
you know
but there is a speed element that misses
to where hey he makes a guy miss he
makes a guy miss but the first guy he
made miss already caught him from behind
to tackle him because he's not fast
enough but yeah there has to be a
certain blend and i agree with you more
times than not you know that
acceleration quickness factor is
probably more important than anything
you say goodbye to the seattle seahawks
uh playoff hopes here as if they had any
real hopes there but are we also saying
goodbye to
the partnership of pete carroll and
russell wilson
it seems that and again i have no inside
info here or anything like that i'm not
trying to break news but it you know
again i think you just you look at the
you know read between the lines whatever
the writing on the wall
it seems that way when you couple that
together what russell said to you last
year after the super bowl in the off
season i know people close to the
situation who also believe that's very
much on his radar how could he how could
he be content with what's going on there
right now that's all i can say i mean
either he gets out of there or he stays
and maybe pete carroll is out of there
or maybe pete finally makes an
adjustment and says okay hey i'll i'll
get an offense and run an offense that
you really want to run but you know
again he's not playing his best football
i know that but how many players did we
watch last night where i i think i've
had fun with you before you know hey you
go straight you go straight and you go
straight down the middle there's there's
lack of creativity there's lack of easy
ways to get the ball into their
playmakers hands there's issues with
that offense and i can't imagine that
russell wilson's happy with the style of
play in which they're playing with right
now or even towards the end of last year
could you see the giants actually going
all in on russell
wilson because that's a rebuild here you
you know
barkley you you got some receivers like
you have some guys who can be good
right are you are you moving on from
daniel jones are you going to move on
from saquon you got to bolster the
offensive line like if i'm russ i'm
going to go okay wait a minute now i'm
going into that situation i know yeah
there's probably better situations now
it is new york and you know i think
there's there is a thought out there
that you know he and his wife would love
to be in that big market but yeah you're
going to have offensive line issues you
talk about it's it's there's a lot of
ifs there with new york right now other
thing i would go is you know i guess i'd
have to see new york actually go that
route of type of quarterback you know
they have a little bit of the the giants
bill parcells have that belichick
believe they kind of want that
traditional pocket passer quarterback
even when i worked in new england it
really there was a a checklist as far as
what you wanted at the quarterback
position as far as size and all the
attributes that go along with it so i'm
not sure if i think that's a match made
in heaven on either side there you know
dolphins are certainly one of those i'd
still throw in the mix the broncos as
we've talked about they're going to be
in quarterback ville at the end of the
year that'd be one that i would intrigue
me if i'm a quarterback they got the
receivers the offensive line certainly
got better this year they got a pretty
good running back i mean that would be
another one that jumps out but i don't
know that giants one i guess i got
you know questions about that one dan
how good are the rams
how about this how dangerous are the
rams they're dangerous as hell i don't
know how good they are i don't know if
they've played their best football as of
yet you know you you saw the game last
night
good not great you know there's just a
a super bowl polish that's missing from
them right now you know again i know
they've won three in a row and they've
righted the ship to a degree there uh it
was good to see their stars pop once
again on the big stage last night the
defense and offense but
i'm not sure i i look at them and go i
know they're a playoff team i know
they're capable of winning a game maybe
two maybe they are uh but but there's
something missing about me thinking
they're a legit
gonna win the super bowl or in that
short list of super bowl teams right now
i guess i'd like to see the defensive
hair more dominant and the offense just
be a hair more consistent i look at it
and go okay yeah they beat the jaguars
they should have arizona great win i get
it but i think we could both sit here
and go arizona served some things up on
a silver plate for them to kind of help
them win that game and then last night's
ugly so i guess i'm kind of waiting to
see what they can kind of grow into here
down the stretch and and what they can
make themselves uh as the playoffs start
but are they similar to dallas that you
have two really good defensive players
on both of those teams and then you have
offenses with offensive minded head
coaches uh you know wanting to pass the
ball although they have a better running
game with two running backs in dallas
but
are there parallels between those two uh
there there is a little bit it's it is
star-oriented there's no doubt you know
i do think like you said dallas has the
capability to run the ball a little bit
better which translates to football you
know but also where i'll say and again i
i even dropped the ball on this a little
bit as the season went on here you know
you just you forget how talented that
balance defense the line is when they're
totally healthy and how deep they are
that's the thing that they have over the
rams too the rams do not have that type
of depth they have to rely on guys
playing a lot of snaps dallas you know
they're a legitimate eight deep on the
defensive line and they can rotate and
give you a lot of different combinations
let alone they can make michael parsons
a defensive lineman at times too to me
with dallas and that defensive line it
kind of puts them okay i'm going to say
a notch above maybe the rams in my eyes
right now even though i got questions
about dallas's offense is too simple dan
that's what i would tell you you know
they're just the passing game simple
people want to know what's wrong with
dak you know again
he spoiled us because he was amazing
early on he's definitely not playing as
hot as he was or as good as he was
waiting but i also look at it why is it
simple
well
the the schemes themselves are simple
and they can get away with it you know
when the run game is really working and
then that invites some basic coverages
hey we gotta stop the run and now they
got the one-on-one playmakers to make
plays happen against those simple
defenses but you know the run game's
been spotty over the last five or six
weeks so i think you couple that with
prescott not being totally on his game
and now teams are going whoa wait we
don't have to put all our eggs into
stopping the run we can play some
coverage stuff you know i watch film
with them every week and there's just
too many plays where i go uh the defense
they
they dropped they were all over this
play they knew what was coming they
played a zone defense there's three
receivers over here and they could they
concocted a defense where everybody
dropped right in that area where they
wanted to attack those are the signals i
start to see when i go
it's a little too simple defenses have
caught on to kind of what you're doing
here as the season went along talking to
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host with mike florio
i thought if brady had a good
performance and the buccaneers beat the
saints he was going to win the mvp
he had one of his worst performances get
shut out now you look at all the
injuries there
and
feels like aaron rodgers is the leading
candidate for the mvp
what do you think i i i i i that's what
i believe no and again i'm not like i
really was saying this for the last
three weeks even before this this you
know saints game and the debacle by the
bucks offense to a degree i don't think
there's a a player in football that's
more important to their offense right
now than aaron rodgers again there's
some good players there we know but we
we can't even decide on who the second
receiver is who is it i don't know is it
valdos scandling is it lazard you know
was it randall cobb i don't know it
doesn't matter it's aaron rodgers i mean
he just he's he's on fire he's playing
unbelievable football
and you know again with brady hey i know
that's a good saints defense but you
know
what i would look at a little bit is the
bills game being up the way they were
they let the bills back in brady kind of
dropped the ball about three or four
series in a row where he had some open
receivers to kind of put the game away
and then you see the other night again i
know brady's awesome but you see the
inability to create anything off
schedule and nights like that and us i
would i would put you know rogers in the
lead right now for for my money
i watched the eagles washington game
last night at least a portion of it i'm
fascinated with jalen hurts i i i don't
know he's a weapon i don't know if he's
a great quarterback right and and that's
it's tricky because you have three
first-round draft picks
uh i don't know if you're going to be in
on any of the quarterbacking sweepstakes
but can you build around jalen hurts
long term
i certainly questioned that before the
year i would have been one that would
have told you no like no that's not
gonna happen you know he just is too
unpolished passing the football like you
said you know and and i feel like there
was a time there early in the year where
they were doing you know the round peg
into the square hull thing you know
nick ciriani coming from the colts and
having some history you know with the
chargers out there i felt like they were
trying to make jalen hurts like philip
rivers in that offense he's not that you
know what they have done is they
evaluated their team to what you're
talking about and said wait we have this
unbelievable offensive line one of the
best offensive lines in football if not
the best and we got a quarterback who
can run and do special things that way
why don't we start to play around those
strengths and that to me is when they
caught fire and i i don't know you know
i said today on pro football talk to
floria i'm kind of getting to the point
now where
he's played enough and i've seen enough
to where i'm gonna go go for it i think
he might be enough to where you go he is
the future we just gotta go
all in kind of lamar jackson baltimore
raven style maybe get one more receiver
to hey speed sweeps and fake this and
fake that and you got devonte smith and
rieger and a good tight end maybe
another running back to the mix to round
out the the stable of rb's there but i
do think you can do it and they're
dangerous dan like i i wouldn't want to
see philadelphia in the playoffs with
that running game chewing up a clock now
you know your offense feels the pressure
of oh gosh we got to make something
happen they go three and out they chew
up the clock again you know they can be
a real pain for somebody if they do get
in and i'm kind of hoping they do
because i think they are one of the
seven best in the nfc i'll leave this uh
with you
tom brady spoke out on his podcast with
jim gray
that he's talked to the nfl players
association he wants to talk to the
competition committee about these hits
these lower body hits these around the
knees hits
um
you can't hit them in the head
even if you go up top you could have a
glancing i mean it that's right it and
and i said this yesterday they like to
make it seem like baseball's strike zone
you know the knees to the armpits that's
not what the strike zone is in baseball
it's it's a circle around your belly
button that's about it and that's where
what that's where we are with football
how do you
how how are you fair to defensive
players here of what you can and can't
do right yeah you're right it's not
the whole sport's become unfair to
defensive players you're not allowed to
hit the quarterback card anymore you
know the horrible call we saw two nights
ago with conklin of the vikings going
down the middle of the field and he gets
hit by dn bush the play that matt nagy
got the personal foul on and i mean he
didn't like you said he hit him in the
chest but he does have a head connected
to him and a helmet and oh maybe it
grazed his helmet oh no yes it's very
tough they've made it hard on these
defensive football players i don't know
what they want them to do certainly
wasn't a dirty hit by pj williams i
understand him going low and doing that
for all the reasons you said you know
and again this is where i want to go
back to like we all know what we signed
up for and every guy going over the
middle would rather be hit in the head
than they would in the knees and i wish
they would just take that aspect away of
like hey we'll still protect the head we
don't want launching at the head but you
know again within reasonable contact and
you're aiming to hit the chest if the
head barely hits the guy in the in the
head okay we're not calling it wasn't
aimed it wasn't a launch at the head to
do that they got to find something
because uh you know like brady is saying
you tear your acl that's that's a big
injury for a wide receiver who's you
know in the middle of his career yeah
and it's unfortunate he's on the last
year of his contract and
but but i if i'm a defensive player and
i'm trying to tackle gronk am i going up
high no i got to go down low
and and it's unfortunate that play it is
it is but but i if i'm a defensive
player i don't know how how would ronnie
lot play today
i i know he'd be like he'd go crazy i
mean again we've taken away
you know one of the great
factors for a team that's built around
defense and that's the fear factor you
want to throw the ball over the middle
you're going to get your head knocked
off you're going to hold the ball in the
pocket we're going to knock your head
off and i don't mean that you know to
the literal term but you know what i'm
saying physicality is what made some of
the great defenses great in the history
of the sport i mean my dad's giants of
86 or the bears of 85 or the broncos of
2015 they wouldn't be the same if you
know some of these rules were just
egregiously in place right now so yes
it's a really tough spot and i think
they call way too many of these
penalties uh on defensive players right
now you're way too young to be a get off
my lawn guy
i know i know but i am because i'm i'm
young but i'm an old soul as far as
football is concerned
and i've watched too many nfl films and
watched my dad's old games to go come on
like i want to protect players i get
that but we've gotten to the point where
if a fingernail hits a quarterback we
throw the penalty flag you know it's
just it's gotten ridiculous here and to
me you're you're severely handicapping
some of the the better defenses in
football with the way the game's getting
called right now yeah i could we need to
change it's like instant replay is not
instant it's just replay and roughing
the passer not every passer gets roughed
right
but but you know grazing the passer you
know nothing we call it nothing the
passer is the phrase i started to use a
few weeks ago on pft it's called nothing
the passer where you just go what like
he just got hit hard but that's not
roughing the passer you know and again
just too much bad offense being rewarded
oh quarterback throws the ball into
triple coverage down the middle of the
field receiver gets hit it's a penalty
and a pass interference no it's a
horrible decision by the quarterback i
mean again we're going to reward hey the
left tackle misses a block up you hit
the quarterback too hard first down
offense we don't care that you were
horrible in pass protection that's what
i don't like that's that's to me where
it's too uh subjective and too much in
the referee's hands right now
thank you chris you're the man dan say
hi to those
merry christmas to all those jerks over
there too all right uh mclovin is
leaving tomorrow tomorrow's his last
show
what yeah yeah oh my gosh all right well
i'll act like i like mclovin for today
then i'm i'm sorry to see him go cause i
love him a lot he's a good dude they're
all good dudes but you know what i mean
they're jerks and they're good dudes
it's it's the same thing thank you see
you mclovin thank you yeah there you go
they're jerks and they're good dudes
yeah yeah makes perfect sense
he was overcome with emotion there that
mclovin was leaving